burning down a real Forest vegan leather
and losing Mel Gibson there's so much
more to Gladiator than we all ever knew
any idea for a film no matter how great
usually has to be conveyed in words
through the screenplay before the on the
groundwork can begin the Genesis of
gladiator was a little different Ridley
Scott explained to variety that his
directing is very quote visually driven
in fact he was so inspired by a 19th
century painting that producer Walter
Park showed him that he immediately
signed up to direct Gladiator without
seeing a script according to Scott ajali
on Jerome painting featuring a gladiator
Standing Tall over his vanquished
opponent was enough to convince him that
gladiator was a movie worth making Scott
explained when you're experienced like
me you can do a little knee-jerk flash
decision and normally it's accurate so I
said I'll do it Park said hang on you
don't know what the story's about I said
I don't care I'll do it and that was it
Russell Crowe mesmerized audiences with
the brooding intensity righteous wrath
principle demeanor and Flair for
violence that best embodies Maximus but
five years earlier Mel Gibson was doing
a similar thing in the guise of William
Wallace in Braveheart both Gladiator and
the movie about the wrong Scot who took
on the might of the English army proved
a similar fact there was still a massive
market for movies with swords stirring
speeches black-hearted villains and lone
Heroes facing overwhelming odds a year
after Gladiator the Lord of the Rings
franchise would unmistakably hammer this
point home according to the New York
Times Gibson was originally offered the
role which made Crow famous the mixture
of sensitive soul and vengeful
psychopath that Gibson brought to bear
on the role of Wallace would have
probably worked equally as well for
Maximus both characters have all they
hold dear wiped out by the callous whims
of egotistical tyrants who represent a
cruel and corrupt regime Wallace and
Maximus also both have a strict sense of
right and wrong even when they're busy
decapitating and disemboweling their
fellow men we got this covered reports
that Gibson passed on the role of
Maximus to play Benjamin Martin in The
Patriot a movie whose mix of
sentimentality and sadism filled to
strike the delicate balance needed to
give Wings Gladiator on the other hand
sword Like a Phoenix
as the ancient world's biggest
amphitheater and an arena where matters
of life and death were decided daily
Rome's Coliseum has left a huge imprint
on History it also left something of a
significant bloodstain the Coliseum is
the perfect symbol of Humanity's dual
urge to create and Destroy with seating
that catered to an audience of 50 000
strong the Coliseum was bringing rock
and roll to the masses centuries before
Elvis Presley or the Beatles today
recreating the imposing and Majestic
architecture of such a structure would
be a simple case of calling the CGI
specialists in but back in 2000 they
prefer to opt for a combination of both
technology and legwork the guardian
reports that Scott was thrilled to be
afforded the chance to bring ancient
Rome to life and wanted to keep the vibe
on set as real as possible heading to a
vacant parade ground in Malta Scott said
about recreating the sprawl sense in
space of Rome on land miles removed from
the Eternal City anyone who's seen
Gladiator will testify to the glory of
the set but it's the Coliseum that
steals the show standing at 16 meters
tall its first tier was built by hand
and the remaining two tiers were a smoke
and mirrors product of the CGI
Department the same method was applied
to its circumference and obeying crowds
yet the effect is Flawless seamless and
is close to Imperial Rome as we're ever
likely to get in this environmentally
aware age burning down a forest just to
give a battle scene added authenticity
would seem a step too far yet with a
budget of over 100 million dollars and a
film to shoot that needed to grip the
viewers attention from the get-go Ridley
Scott needed to go big fortunately for
the director a large area of the forest
in Surrey England where the opening
scene in Gladiator is filmed was
scheduled for deforestation prior to
filming the sun reports that when Scott
got wind of the forthcoming call he
contracted the forestry commission and
offered to kill two birds with one stone
the authorities got someone to maintain
born wood free of charge and Scott God
got the heat and fury of a bona fide
battle in the heart of Germania at its
heart Gladiator is a simple Revenge
story The cruel and overprivileged Ward
of the manor ruins a good and Noble
man's life out of pure Spite and toxic
envy and the hero vows to right this
wrong by waiting knee-deep in a torrent
of Carnage and blood Gladiator is the
sort of Epic and emotive movie that
doesn't need an intricate plot to make
it work however it was heavily
influenced by a book that screenwriter
David franzoni stumbled across by chance
in Baghdad when he was a young college
graduate in the 1970s Film School
rejects reports that Daniel P maddox's
those about to die AKA The Way of the
Gladiator left a big mark on franzoni
who was enthralled by Tales of those who
fought and died in the Roman games the
factual book is a No Holds Barred
account of the true depravity and
Slaughter that took place in Roman
Arenas in the name of entertainment
franzoni decided it could provide the
raw materials of a great movie in the
final product historical facts were
approached with a certain Liberty and
the Roman Empire was given a modern
makeover to make the gladiatorial games
look more relevant to our age of huge
sporting events but the essence of the
Gory and disturbing details franzoni
found in manix's book remained Gladiator
gave the vicarious generation of a new
millennium a raw and bloody Taste of how
the Ancients used to get their rocks off
as well as being prodigal talents The
Late Oliver Reed and Richard Harris also
had a reputation for being committed and
uncompromising with his star on the rise
at the time Russell Crowe also had a
similar no-nonsense head down approach
to the art of acting and life putting
all three prickly thespians on the set
of an alpha male type movies such as
Gladiator was always going to be a
combustible situation according to a
piece in the sun Paris who plays Marcus
Aurelius announced on day two of filming
I've read that I am in a movie starring
Oliver Reed can I make one thing clear I
would never be caught dead in a movie
starring Oliver
are we understood as for Reed when not
busy playing Gladiator trainer proximo
he was busy drinking heavily arm
wrestling with Sailors and getting
banned from Hotel Bars as for Russell
Crowe well it's safe to say Ridley Scott
had his hands full recalling his time on
the set Garth Pierce wrote in the Sun
that Crow did a lot of moaning about the
script the weather and the boredom
Ridley Scott finally exploded and
snarled he thinks he can pull that
with me I'll go back to Hollywood and
bury him Scott would later add he had to
learn there was only one person in
charge and that was the director on the
Eve before Oliver Reed died of a fatal
heart attack the sun reports the
hard-living 61 year old had downed a
phenomenal amount of alcohol the next
morning was another non-filming day and
he returned to his favorite local pub
early on in the day later his power was
worrisome and his wife called an
ambulance however it was too late as
Reed died before he could finish filming
his last scene for Gladiator crew member
Rob Harris explained that when filming
recommenced we all waited for words from
Ridley Scott which never came it was the
case of into the valley of death forward
March although Reed has a relatively
small role in Gladiator as the slave
dealer who owns Maximus it is an
integral one in the wake of Reed's death
Scott was faced with the problem of how
to seamlessly finish the film and honor
Reed's memory the answer came as it so
often does in the shape of Technology
Scott explained to variety we managed to
finish off what was required from Oliver
stealing digital images of his face and
attaching them to an appropriate body
although an easy task by today's
standards at the turn of the century
such cinematic trickery was completely
novel it was expensive too to the tune
of 3.2 million dollars spent for just
two minutes of screen time featuring the
image of Reed from Beyond the Grave
Russell Crowe explained to variety that
he never liked the original script for
Gladiator yet the opportunity to work
with Ridley Scott was too good an
opportunity to miss screenwriter David
Franz Zoni revealed that he and Scott
were determined to steer well clear of
the classic sword and sandal movies and
used foreign cinema as their blueprint
it was also open to cast members
suggesting various ideas for major read
rights during pre-production and
throughout the entire shoot Scott
franzoni and Crow often met during
filming to discuss how the script could
be given an extra charge of energy and
new dialogue was often written on the
hoof franzoni explained we'd all drink
whiskey and smoke cigars we'd exchange
notes and ideas then I'd go back and
write it three or four in the morning
and I'd hand the pages to Ridley during
the shoot I went off and met with
Russell we would meet almost daily
before he would go shoot and talk about
the scenes I remember once we were
sitting on the ground drawing things in
the sand it was a very 60s way to make a
film Pro added jokingly I've often said
to Ridley since one of these days we
should actually do a film where we know
what we're going to do before we start
although Maximus and Emperor comedus are
Arch enemies in the film off-screen
Russell Crowe and Joaquin Phoenix became
the best of buddies following his
brother River Phoenix's death Gladiator
was one of the first big Productions
that Joaquin appeared in Crow explains a
variety that during the publicity rounds
for Gladiator a lot of journalists would
bombard Phoenix they'd ask him questions
about his brother because Maximus and
Commodus initially share a brotherly
bond in the film prodding Phoenix about
how he felt about his co-star Crow
explained at one point we were doing
some press conference and Phoenix just
said something along the lines of look
Russell treated me like a brother and it
just hit me in a really heavy way
cinema.com reports that Crow also
revealed he helped Phoenix overcome his
nerves on the set of gladiator by
sharing a few key Libations Crow
explained that it was Richard Harris who
suggested all three actors sit down
together have a drink and discuss what
was bothering Phoenix Crow added we
talked about how Phoenix requires an
external Force to get him into the
moment and through a number of hours and
a number of cans of Guinness I got the
point across to him that it's actually
in Eternal journey and everything he
needs to do with the character lives
within him an actor's life isn't all
about Mass adulation award ceremonies
talk shows and meet and greet events on
the red carpet in Russell Crowe's case
playing in alpha males such as Maximus
and Gladiator actually left him black
blue bloodied and bruised as well as
smashing up his hip and breaking a foot
bone during his time as a sword and
shield man Crow also had a close call
with one of the Tigers but fortunately
Live to Tell The Tale in an interview
with w e n n Crow revealed the days of
doing his own stunts are long behind him
because his body is no longer capable of
bouncing back in the same way anymore
listing the injuries he had picked up on
set Crow said I've got no cartilage in
my toes anymore I've got great four
tears in both Achilles tendons I've got
shin splints I've got bone marrow edemas
under both knees I've got one
disintegrating hip I've got a rib in my
upper thoracic that pops off my spine
this stuff comes from committing to the
job and giving myself over to the job
after killing Emperor Commodus and
finally avenging the murders of his wife
child and surrogate father Maximus gives
in to the ravages and wounds inflicted
upon his body and dies so that Justice
might live it's an emotive and fitting
ending to Gladiator and it's difficult
to see how Maximus could have survived
without lessening the film's impact
however although the death of Maximus
seems inevitable in the film's original
screenplay Maximus would have lived this
seems vastly at odds with the character
whose only motivation and ambition in
life is to kill Commodus red roam of
corruption and reunite with his family
in the afterlife Maximus has no appetite
for life but he has an insatiable thirst
for vengeance and once that's quenched
it's difficult to imagine him starting
over on some rural small holding
somewhere it was a concern held by both
Ridley Scott and Russell Crowe who told
Empire that my name is Maximus speech is
basically a suicide note I remember
deadly coming up to me on set saying
look the way this is shaping up I don't
see how you live the character is about
one act of pure Vengeance for his wife
and child and once he's accomplished
that what does he do Crow revealed he
had a long-running joke that in an
alternate universe the world weary and
battle-hardened Warrior could have ended
up running a pizza joint near the
Coliseum fortunately everybody reached
an agreement that fate was firmly fixed
for Maximus and it didn't involve
pepperoni although they enjoyed a fierce
reputation as a nation-state built on
blood and Conquest being a vegetarian or
a vegan in ancient Rome was not as
unusual as you might think according to
Encyclopedia Britannica many ancient
greco-romans were Keen proponents of the
plant and mineral diet in Rome only the
rich could afford to tear into animal
flesh regularly but because polyester
and spandex weren't a thing back then
your average Roman would have had to
wear wool or leather this posed a tricky
dilemma of four long-term vegan Joaquin
Phoenix when it came to playing the
bloodthirsty Emperor Commodus as a
merciless dictator and vengeful Tyrant
Commodus has no qualms about butchering
everything and anything if it offends
his sensibilities obviously wearing the
skin of a dead animal is not going to be
a bone of contention for such a man yet
according to ABC News so Fierce are
Phoenix's vegan principles he refused to
wear leather when playing the Roman
Overlord and the costume Department had
to Kit him out with a synthetic
substitute Peter reports that Phoenix
who has made the same stance on his
Wardrobe when playing characters in
other films such as the Johnny Cash
biopic Walk the Line explained my
lifestyle is part of who I am and
therefore is always a consideration when
working I always discuss this with
producers and they are very
accommodating despite being a concise
self-contained and satisfying story
which leaves no stone unturned or loose
end to clutch onto for over 20 years
there have been varying levels of demand
for either a sequel or prequel to
Gladiator perhaps Keen to have another
taste of the intoxicating commercial and
critical success both Ridley Scott and
Russell Crowe have at some point given
the idea some serious thought according
to deadline Paramount confirmed Ridley
Scott would be directing the decades
later sequel to Gladiator it's set to
feature Paul meskel as Lucius from the
original movie who's now all grown up
years after maximus's death you may
remember that Lucius was the young
nephew of Joaquin Phoenix's Emperor
Commodus will Lucius be the new champion
of the Coliseum we'll have to wait and
see until Gladiator 2 hits theaters on
November 22nd 2024.
[Music]